कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखे हिंदी में कि ने इस
एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम सिर्फ 10
में वर्ड सीखने वाले हैं कितने सिर्फ 10
और उस वर्ड के साथ हम नए 10 पेंशन सीखने
वाले हैं और 10 प्रकार से हम दो वाक्यों
को जोड़ना सीखने वाले हैं इंट्रस्टिंग है
राय और उसके लिए क्या जरूरी है कि हमारी
बेसिक कंजंक्शन की संस्कृति जो हमने
मोबाइल वैन तुलसी का था उसका एपिसोड नंबर
तब 22 वह आपकी क्लियर होनी चाहिए अगर नहीं
है तो वह देख कर आओ ड्रॉप क्लियर है तो आज
हम को सिर्फ 1098 सीखने मतलब क्या क्यों
वजह से वहां पर सीखा था आए ड्रिंक पी
बिकॉज़ आई लाइक पी हमने क्या किय था कर
आपको याद है इस प्रेम करते वाइल्ड इस टेप
मां अ हम ने क्या बोला था वही लें जो
करेक्टर बीच में आएगा और जो मां हैं जो
चलने वाला वर्ग है वह एंड में जाएगा यह
क्रॉस का क्लियर है तो आज एकदम सिंपल
कि जब हमारे 10 कनेक्टर सीखे हो जाएंगे
मैंने नीचे डिस्क्रिप्शन में 10 क्वेश्चन
दिए हुए हैं आप उस सॉल्व करने की कोशिश
करो उसके नीचे उसके आंसर भी दिए हैं तो
आपको पता चलेगा कि आपको यह कंफर्म समझने
आई है या नहीं तो शुरू करते हैं सारे
कंजक्शन सीखना पहला मेरा सबसे फेवरेट है
दांत डांस मतलब हिंदी इंग्लिश में होगा
डाइनर भी चांदी से देखकर वे मस्ट लर्न
जर्मन वियर मिशन लांच न अच्छा लगता है
उसका अगर मैं बोलूं आई थिंक दैट भी मस्ट
लर्न जर्मन
है कि शोएब को इस टेंडर डाला था द टैंकर
राज वीडियो देख लूनर मिशन मिशन एंड में
क्यों गया तो यह कंडीशन वाला चलने वाला
वर्ग तक वह इससे आपको याद है इस दिन का
दास भी अदरवाइज चेयरमैन उसन समझ में अभिनय
को और थोड़ा अच्छा लगे आइए अब ओपिनियन दैट
इज मस्ट लर्न जर्मन फ्रेंच है इस महीने
दायक जयहे लेयर न मिशन और तर्क देते हैं
कि वह इस भूमिका गुरुंग कि बाबा ने जर्मन
चाहिए इस तरह अवधेश दास वीर वीर दास
माइक्रम बहुत अच्छा कर सकते हैं यह सारे
जो हैं
चीनी गए इस बैंक व देहात इस विनर - मदर
स्टिल हैव बीन स्टॉप्ड फ्रॉम दिस या आप
लगा सकते हो और उसके आपका जो सेंटेंस एकदम
अलग लेवल का हो जाता है यह आपको स्पेशल
एग्जाम्स में बहुत काम आएगा और बेसिक
वर्किंग दो सिंपल है लड्डू है वह जो चलने
वाला था वह एंड मिल जाएगा करना कुछ भी
नहीं पर सेंट्रल से कम हाई लेवल प्लग
ए विलेन जब यह सुनो क्वेश्चन पूछते हो यस
नो क्वेश्चन मतलब क्या मालूम लिस्ट में है
क्या इस मार्किंग भर लीजिए इस मार्किंग
बैकलिंक जानवर में कैसे होगा इस्ट मार्क
इन बैरिंग सीरवी अब इसको हम थोड़ा सा एकदम
डिफरेंट करते हैं आई वांट टू नो इट्स
मार्क कि जिन पर लेंगे अब यह जो इंग्लिश
में अपने क्या किया हमने इस पर लगा है तो
यह क्यों लगाया क्यों इनडायरेक्ट स्पीच था
कब वेदर भी बोलते हैं और वांट टो नो वेदर
मार्किंग दिन भर लें जर्मन में उसके लिए
है वह तो क्या होगा देखो इस मिनिस्टर मिशन
ओम मार्क इन बे रिड्यूस्ड इट्स सिर्फ एंड
सिंपल ओम मतलब वेदर इन इंग्लिश में यूज
करते थे वह संजय दत्त
ए सिमिलर की थर्ड करेक्टर जो है वह Bigg
Boss क्वेश्चन ओके लव यू स्टे क्वेश्चंस
मतलब क्या वह व्वे राजू आप इंग्लिश में
पूछता है तो वह हमने कम डिटेल में सीखे
हैं राइड तो अगर आपको पूछना है जो कि हाउ
मच कॉस्ट कॉस्ट हाउ मच कॉस्ट कॉस्ट तो
क्या होता है बीपीएल कार्ड स्टेटस VPN को
स्टेटस ओके अब इंग्लिश में अगर आपको पूछना
तक कैन यू प्लीज टेल मी हाउ मच डिड कॉस्ट
अगर आप देखोगे जब आप नार्मल सेंटेंस बनाते
थे अपने डैड लगाया था कि आई थिंक दैट
विश्वविद्यालय जर्मन डेट कनेक्ट अर्थात यह
क्वेश्चन था तब अपने इफिजी आफ वेदर लगाया
आई वांट टू नो इस मार्केट जिंक यूनिक और अ
इस पर जब अपने डेबिट से क्वेश्चन से दो
चीजें जोड़ी आपने कुछ कलेक्टर नहीं लगाया
क्योंकि दबी नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन है इट्स
इफैक्ट्स आफ बस कंडक्टर कैन यू प्लीज टेल
मी हाउ मच द्रविड़ को ऑफ मंज़िल कॉस्ट ईयर
है सबको जर्मन में भी एक्जेक्टली से जवाब
w10 क्वेश्चन यूज करोगे तो वोट डे
क्वेश्चन ही ऐसा कनेक्ट करेक्ट करेगा आपको
अलग कनेक्ट अलग यूज करने की जरूरत नहीं है
सिर्फ अज्ञात दिशा कंडोम निबंधक सर्वर
बैंक में जाएगा तो यह क्लासिकल के VPN को
स्टेटस का क्या होगा चैनल सीनियर्स अगर
कॉर्नर वी लेस कॉस्ट सिर्फ वह स्टूडेंट
मिल गया पर कॉल सेंटर कितना भारी हो गया
वह कैसे लगता है कि अनंत सिंह है जहां धन
वीसीयस कॉस्ट एंड अगेन वेरी उसफुल इन
एग्जाम वैसे आपको अगर बोल रहा है कि वही
वह इसके हकदार तो आप नार्मल क्या बोलोगे
वह इसके हकदार है वह इस के तौर पर इस
कार्यक्रम से तड़का लगा कि कैसे हुं
का जन्मदिन था वह किधर संजय एकदम सिंपल तो
यह के तीन कनेक्टर जो कैंटर इनडायरेक्ट
स्पीच रिकॉर्ड कौन से दास और दिल्ली
ऐडमिशन अब हम और दो कलेक्टर सीखते हैं जो
एग्जाम सिंपल तो सबसे पहले वे रणबीर एंड
मतलब ड्यूरिंग यह ज्यादा यूज नहीं करते
मतलब क्या आई डोंट टॉक वैन ड्राइवर गाड़ी
चला तो मैं बात नहीं करता रहेगा तो क्या
होगा देखो इस रेड नेक्स्ट वेरोनिक इस पर
इस रेड लिस्ट वेरोनिक पिंपल्स और जैसे
आपको ड्यूरिंग के लिए यह पता होना चाहिए
और कंडक्टर है जो कि यूज नहीं करते फिर हम
सीखेंगे व है पाल पाल मतलब इन इनके मतलब
अगर वह नहीं तो मैं नहीं तो क्या होगा
अपनी प्ले इनके सिर नॉट प्ले आई विल प्ले
इन ए सीरियस नोट तो क्या होगा इस वंश
विलेन इश्वर अपील अनफेयर नेट स्पीड स्पीड
सिर्फ मजा आएगा कि कुछ एकदम सिंपल अब यह
इंपोर्टेंट वन मैसेज करो कि थोड़े से
सिंपल करें इंपोर्टेंट बनने जा रहे हैं तो
इंपोर्टेंट 130 आलू आपके पास में कोई घटना
घटित होती है जो जनरली एक ही बार होती है
तब उसको क्लिक करें कि मैं जब मैं 10 साल
का था तब मैंने इंग्लिश जब मैं 15 साल का
था तब मैंने स्कूटर चलाना तो यह जो हैं
उनके लिए यूज होता है कि जो पैटर्न है वह
रहेगा तो देखते हैं इंग्लिश ईयर्स ओल्ड
व्हेन स्ट्रेंजर्स
है तो क्या होगा इस हफ्ते इंग्लिश ग्लू ऑल
युधिष्ठिर यार अल्टो कार पेंट है दूसरा
सेंटेंस नॉर्मली इश्वर उसमें से हटके चैनल
आल्सो अरे वाह एकदम सिंपल साइड अब एक
Simple सी लेते हैं B4 B4 B4 को जर्मन में
बोलते हैं और डॉक्टर को बोलते हैं और एक
सिंपल इंग्लिश अगर आपको है कि मिल्क इसलिए
इसलिए तो क्या बोलोगे तो
ए स्प्रिंग कमिसन बिफोर स्लीप एकदम सिंपल
सिर्फ जैसे इंग्लिश में था वैसे ही अब
यहां पर दो यह वर्ड है इसलिए वह वर्मा
मेंडक आप टेंशन नहीं आया उल्टा कर सकते हो
ना इसलिए आफ्टर आयोडीन मिल्क आई स्लीप
आफ्टर आयोडीन मिले तो वह क्या होगा इस लूप
को इस लौ को ना कदम इस मिर्च यह जरूर कहा
व मालिक होता इछावर मिर्च के थ्रू कहना या
ट्रंक मिल्क से हाथों क्या होगा एंटर में
जाएगा इस्लाम फल ना कदम इस अधिकतम कर हां
बगैर मेरी सिंपल जैसे आप इंग्लिश में यूज
करते हो वैसे ही सिर्फ नए वर्ड्स आप
सीखोगे रेट अभिनेता शरमन रखैल है कि जो
ज्यादा यूज नहीं होता एग्जाम है कितनी बार
इंग्लिश में आप यूज करते हुए बिलों है कि
जो लोग जो लंग तो वह कैसे वर्क होता है
देखो कि भई
कि आई विल प्लेयर्स ओं थिस प्लेस विल प्ले
अलोंग डिस्प्ले तो क्या होगा इस वर्ष पीर
वेस्टफील्ड प्लीज थोड़ा सा उपाय अगर आपको
करना है तो वह आपको आपको शोले का डायलॉग
याद होगा जब तक तुम्हारे पैर चलेंगे तब तक
उसकी साथ चलेंगी रेट सोंठ इस बेसिकली कमी
के बाद तक फैसलों के डांस की विल राइट
क्लिक हेयर लोंग एस यू डांस तो क्या का यह
लूप को दूर ट्रांस फैट लूज जो लंगर दूध
ओके अभी हम लास्ट वन देखते हैं कि हम
लास्ट वन देखते हैं जो अगेन इंपोर्टेंट है
इसलिए नियमित जो बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है उससे
स्टार्ट किया अब हम दाम में डायबिटिस तो
दैट यह इंपोर्टेंट है इस्लाम एंड करेंगे
शोधक मतलब क्या है फिर दाग मिट क्या बोलता
है कि द्वारा उद्देश बताता है
हां बोलो फॉर एग्जांपल मैं फल और सब्जियां
खाता हूं जिससे कि शो दैट कि मैं हेल्दी
रह आई डोंट फ्रूट्स एंड वेजिटेबल्स शोल्ड
बेग पधारो मेन हल्दी तो क्या होगा कि हम
नॉर्मली स्पोर्ट्स टूट के म्यूट द दाम
मिनट इस यह डोंट ब्लैकबर्न का दाम मिड
लेवल का नागिन रिप्लेस टेबल कारण में गया
क्योंकि यह वह उस तक का करैक्टर है एकदम
सिंपल एंड टोटल 10 टाइप के करेक्टर सीटें
हैं अभी कुछ भी नहीं है इसमें अगर आपको
ऑइल यूज करना आता तो यह अपने सिर 10 न
अवार्ड ठीक हैं सिर्फ अव्वल मैडम में गया
है क्लियर अभी देखिए जब आपको याद होगा
वहां पर भी हमने बोला था कि कभी-कभी हम
ऐसे भी बोल सकते हैं कि भई वायरल इस तेल
मात्र इनका स्टे आप वालों का जो class है
वह पहले ला सकते हो तो उसमें मैं क्या हूं
के पूर्व वीसी का क्रॉस पहले लाया पर वह
पहला को जो पहले लाया वह क्लासिफिकेशंस
फर्स्ट पोजिशन इसीलिए मैंने इसमें से
कंट्रोल सिस्टम तक रहा है वह तो अगर आपको
ज्यादा आज आपने क्या बोला था वाइल इस
मैं तेरी मां अ अतिरिक्त रिश्ते उसके बाद
कामाख्या पत्रिका आया था यहां भी मोस्ट ऑफ
द रिसीवर जो बिफोर है वरन है ऑल फेल्ट यह
ऐसे पहले पोजीशन पर आते हैं मतलब आज शिष्य
थे नहीं आ रहा व्यवहार हाव-भाव इष्ट 2 इंच
हवाई इंग्लिश कैलेंडर कॉम के बाद हवा एक
पहली चीज है जब फर्स्ट पोजिशन वर्क करती
है सेकेंड पोजीशन पर हां अब वे हैव इस फिर
ऑडिशन इट्स रिच लिस्ट क्लियर है
हैं या फिर बिफोर इस्लाम व प्रियंका इश्क
मिर्च प्रियंका इस मिर्च याद रखना
व्यक्तिगत वर्ग या कुमार है कि वह पहला जो
अ ग्लास है वह अ फर्स्ट पोजिशन नेक्स्ट कर
रहें हैं एकदम सिंपल है बट अगर आपकी बेसिक
कंसेप्ट लिए तो आज हम सिर्फ 10 नए वर्ड्स
सीख और हमने 10 तरह से सेंटेंसेस को
जोड़ना सीखा है अभी इसके नीचे और
डिसक्रिप्शन में मैंने और 10 सेंटेंसेस
दिए हैं आप वह सॉल्व करने की कोशिश करो वह
आंसर कि उसके नीचे दिए हैं तो आपको पता
चलेगा कि आपकी कंसेप्ट कितने क्लियर है
मुझे आशा है कि आपको यह कनेक्ट समझ में आई
होगी हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में
धन्यवाद